Well. Good morning and welcome to talks
at Google in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Today it's my great pleasure to
introduce the great and Jane Lightman.
Jean is one of Boston's most exceptional
representational artists and teachers
as a teacher.
She passes on the knowledge and techniques
she has received as one in the line
of Boston School of painters that
has been unbroken for over a century.
This was a remarkable lineage,
I believe is unique and
the American art community.
She can describe it far better than I
can and I'll leave it to her to do some.
Gene holds a distinguished
artists membership at the
Concord Art Association and
became a Copley artist member of the
Copley Society Boston in 2004 in 1989 she
was elected a member of the prestigious
guild of Boston artists where she
currently serves as vice president of
the board of managers and curated a major
historical exhibition,
a woman's perspective,
founding and early women members of the
guild of Boston artists 1914 to 1945
please join me in
welcoming Jane White Man.
Thank you, Jonathan. Thank
you all for coming today.
It's an honor to be here at Google and
have the opportunity to talk with you
about art. And in particular
the art of the Boston School,
which is not a physical school is Jonathan
explained it's a painting tradition
that's been handed down from teacher
to student for over 100 years.
Yeah.
And uh, in my talk today I'll
introduce the Boston school painters,
the founders show you the work of the
founders and I'm also the European masters
who influenced them as
well as their successors.
Okay.
I'll also show you images of my own work
and explain how I include the essential
elements of the Boston
school and to my painting.
So,
uh,
okay.
The Boston school painters are essentially
impressionist in the sense that they
paint what the eye sees with particular
attention to the lights and the shadows
and the colors
because their paint,
what there,
I actually sees some areas are more
distinct and others are more diffused.
So there are sometimes
called optical realist.
And this should be distinguished from
photo realist where in photo realism
painting,
every square inch of the canvas
is painted in precise everything.
And in the exact same focus,
but the way that we actually see is some
areas are more defined and others are
more diffused and so that's the way the
Boston school painters like to paint.
As you can see,
they don't all paint alike,
but they're all interested in how
the light falls across their subject.
Okay,
and the most important trade mark or the
Boston school painters is that all of
the parts must relate to the whole
giving the paintings unity or breadth.
Okay.
Probably the earliest vulva
impressionist painter was Velasquez,
Diego Velasquez who painted
this beautiful scene,
Las Meninas and you can see how he has
captured the light and the relationships
of the light as they fall on on the scene
and pay close attention to the dwarf
and the dog and the lower right hand
corner because they're beautiful examples
of impressionists sing.
Okay.
From Mira was another impressionist
and the way that we're using this term,
he was fascinated by how light fell
across the scene and his paintings have a
truth or the look of nature.
You feel like you're in the room with,
with the subject.
Okay.
He's arranged the model next to the
window and he's described how the light
falls across her arm and across the top
of her head covering the back wall and
onto the table.
And he's painted relational color.
He was one of the first
painters and really the only
Dutch painter to understand
that there's color in the halftones,
which is the area between
the lights and the shadows.
And here he's painted this beautiful
blue note and the top of her head,
her head covering,
and he's looking at relational colors.
So rather than painting this breasts,
pitcher and,
and bowl a yellow as
it would be in in life,
he's showing you that it's reflected
in all the colors around it.
So this is relational color
versus absolute color.
And you'll see this over and over
again in the Boston school paintings.
Okay.
Chardon also include an influenced the
Boston school painters and he painted
beautifully composed,
still lives using simple kitchen objects
and note how he paints these beautiful
abstractions of lights
and shadows as they, uh,
move across the canvas.
Okay?
In the late 19th century,
Americans flocked to Europe to study art.
In the academies,
particularly in France and Germany.
And they learn,
they're the essentials of
painting and in particular design,
which was a key element,
so important in academic painting.
And this painting by Joe Only owns your
Rome called Gray Eminence hangs in the
Museum of fine arts. It's a wonderful
example of academic painting.
And I learned from a Google search.
The Gray Eminence refers to the power
behind the throne. In this case,
this monk standing on the stairs who
was the power behind the throne in the
court of King Louis, the
13th. And Cardinal Richelieu,
Edmund Tarbell is considered the
founder of the Boston school. In fact,
the early painters we'll
call terrible lights,
he traveled to France as a
young art student in 1883
and studied in the academy.
Julienne there.
He learned the fundamentals of
drawing and design and painting.
But he and the other early Boston
painters, Boston school painters,
and I'll show you their work in a minute.
We're influenced also by the color and
the light of the French impressionist.
And uh,
they incorporated those to the color
and light and the drawing and design.
And they brought those back to Boston
and taught them what became known as the
Boston school tradition. And note
here, and you should blur your eyes,
which is the way to look at a lot
of these paintings with a blurred I,
you can see the abstractions of dark
silhouettes cut into the light starting on
the bottom left corner of the canvas and
traveling up and down and up until he
gets to the right upper right corner.
Beautiful abstractions.
And like for mere,
he's fascinated with the play of light
across the models neck and also across
the wall throughout the whole scene.
This is also by bell and
a wonderful portrait.
Again,
abstract did abstract had saying of
lights and that are silhouetted against a
dark background.
The painter here shows is the beautiful
form and colors in her face and her arms
and also in her her dress.
And he's seeking something
here that, um, is, is a unique,
I think to a lot of the Boston school
painters trying to find the beauty, uh,
the whole harmony and the round forms
that you see when you look at the scene is
reminiscent of John
Singer Sargent portraits.
And people often ask me if sergeant was
a Boston school painter, but he was not.
He painted in Europe, um, studied
in Europe, like the Boston painters,
but his paintings are a little
bit different. And as you can see,
the models is that he's a genius. And I'm
not taking anything away from sergeant.
He was an absolutely superb, phenomenal
painter and a number of different genres,
not just portrait,
but he's not seeking out the subtle color
tones and the round form in the face
and the neck and the arms,
which I think you can see here.
He's painting a sort of
lively, um, painterly,
um,
ensemble of lights and darks.
Frank Benson was another early Boston
school painter and he liked Tarbell study
that the academy,
Julianne and Paris.
Yeah,
his outdoor paintings glow with sunlight.
Okay.
As you can see here, he's also fascinated
by the colors, the relational colors,
the blues and the yellows on her dress.
Also on the inside of the
boat and on his son's shirt.
These are his children here.
The whole painting is a wonderful ensemble
of blues and yellows with a little
hint of reds in here for some interest.
Okay.
Benson was also an avid
outdoorsman and he, uh,
as he,
um,
he also did beautiful etchings
and paintings of wildlife.
And notice here his wonderful designs,
the,
the would call what's called
negative shapes here of the, uh,
inside the wings of the Canada
geese and how he's spaced them.
He sort of has a wonderful rhythm here
that's played out from here to here to
here.
It's a really beautiful example of design,
very simple design and,
and Vinson was a master at that.
Okay.
Another early Boston school painter
was Joseph to Camp who studied with,
um, uh, frank douvenette in
Germany. Notice here. He's,
this is also a wonderful
example of Boston school.
What's essential to the Boston school,
which is lost and found.
So, um, uh, found edge, uh,
is where the light and the shadow or
contrast and so this would be a found a
edge here.
The shadow against the background.
Also her just very,
you have to look closely,
but her chin here against the
background is a found edge.
This is a law sedge under her neck.
So this just dissolves
into the background.
The same thing with the back of her
hair that dissolves into the back of her
neck and shoulder.
And then all the way down into the apron
and now look at how her apron dissolves
into the tabletop,
the shadows on the tabletop.
And then this wonderful still life here
of porcelain objects is a great example
of lost and found. So this
is a, a found edge here,
which is sharp here against
the black of her apron.
This would be a lost edge where the other,
other side of this porcelain
dissolves into the background.
So you'll see lost and found repeated
in a lot of the Boston school work.
Okay.
William Paxton studied with Joseph Decamp,
our previous painter and
Paxton Excel did interiors.
I'm very much influenced by Vermeer.
This is a painting at the Museum of
fine arts called the new necklace.
Okay,
this is another wonderful
painting by Paxton.
I'm also at the Museum of Fine Arts and
another great example of lost and found
and also beautiful impressionist color.
So you here some lost edges here and um,
very simple,
not highly defined,
a licensed shadows in the face which
dissolve into the back of the neck.
But you really have to see this
painting at the museum to appreciate the
absolutely gorgeous colors that the artist
puts into her back. And also her arm.
And notice the beautiful form on both
his wife Elizabeth Paxon was also a
wonderful painter and she excelled at it
still life paintings.
He or she makes this terrific
ensemble of a mass of objects.
It's called the breakfast tray and
she has a variety of edges here.
This is all an angle.
So here's a sharp angle here around
a sharp edge on the edge of the cup,
beautiful variety of edges and the Napkin
and also wonderful color ensembles.
These yellows and blues
harmonize beautifully and
then she has a little note of
red here for interest.
Okay.
William Paxton,
student Ives gamble was responsible for
carrying that tradition on through the
20th century.
He taught a number of students in the
forties and the fifties sixties I guess 50
sixties and seventies when this tradition
was very much out of favor with the
artists and the arts schools of the day.
A gamble,
loved painting, these sort of
allegorical paintings. But again,
note the beautiful Carmona
is color relationships.
I love the blues and the yellows and
this painting and then he has also some
notes of Rudd.
Okay.
The PA,
the Boston school tradition would have
surely died out if it hadn't been for
gamble and a number of his
students have gone on to teach,
including my teacher.
Okay.
One of his early students
was Robert Douglas Hunter.
You might be familiar with his still
lives. He was a very well known,
a still life painter and also noted
for is harmonious compositions.
Um,
he painted what he said all nature in one
glance and it does feel like this is a,
uh,
this classical still life has a
beautiful harmony or unity about it.
Okay.
Gambles student.
One of his students was Paul Ingrid Son,
who was my teacher and Paul Excelled.
He's also has gone on to teach oh,
dozens of painters over the last 30
years in mansion now in Manchester.
New Hampshire has an Italia,
Paul Excels at portraits,
civilized interiors figures,
and this is a beautiful portrait of a
dancer. Uh, one of my favorites of his,
and he has uses a full
use of relational color,
beautiful color transitions between the,
the warm notes in her cheek across the,
around 400 chic to the cooler
blue notes at the edge of her jaw.
Also beautiful soft round
edge at the edge of her jaw.
Okay.
And across her neck. And more than
that, more the tech, more the,
uh, more than the technical
accomplishments of this painting,
he's infused the, the, uh,
portrait with expression in life.
Okay.
This is Pauline Robertson's Italia in
New Hampshire and this is one of his cast
drawing students.
When the student begins to study
in the Boston school tradition,
the first thing you do is you'd make do
charcoal drawings of these white plaster
casts.
And that's what the student is doing here.
And that's what I did when I
first started studying, um,
in the late eighties with Paul.
So this is my cast drawing and
it's the perfect teaching tool.
It's, it's the, um,
the opportunity for the
teacher to what's called true,
the eye of the student to
recognize values and proportions.
Everything is seen relationally.
So I learned to see the height
and relation to the width.
I learned to see how my values,
how dark my shadows had to be in order
to make my lights pop out and get what's
called a light effect,
which is so important in this painting.
Okay.
And I also learned to
distinguish a variety of edges,
as I've already pointed out.
So there's sharp edges where the
value contrast or the highest.
And then in order to describe the form,
I had to learn to understand softer edges.
And how to make things look round.
And of course in Socrates beard here,
I had infinite opportunity to do that.
Okay.
This is um,
Paul's teaching studio and uh,
where I studied in
Roxbury back in the 80s.
And a few things to point out about
the studios for these Boston school
painters. First of all, you notice
that the wall color is a middle value.
It's not white.
We never use white walls because the
light bounces all over white walls.
And so it's hard to see what your,
the light is doing on your setup.
This is the setup here.
Also,
we have high Northlight
because Northlight is steady,
there's no sun shining through to,
um,
to change the shadows. So the shadows
are fairly consistent throughout the day.
Okay.
Another thing I want to
point out is in our painting,
we actually have to stand back from the
setup and the Easel at least three times
the height of the painting so that
you can see the whole thing at once.
Because obviously you're
trying to get harmony or unity.
So you have to be able to see all of the
relationships that the values and the
colors and the proportions all as
Robert Hunter said in one glance.
So you stand back and then you look at
the painting and the setup and then you
actually walk up and paint from memory.
So I'm not looking at the setup
when I'm painting this painting.
Yeah,
it's just an interesting note.
So I studied with Paul for
almost 10 years and um,
finally cut the umbilical cord and the
early nineties and started painting on my
own in a studio in Concord,
Massachusetts.
And I enjoy doing portraits
of kids, children. I've also,
because they have nice round form
and their faces and I love that. Um,
I also liked doing landscapes.
This is a painting of the Minuteman
statue with the Northbridge and conquered.
Okay.
But my passion is flowers
and in particular pns,
um,
what I love about them are the round
shapes and just like the figures with the
white dresses and the earlier
paintings that you saw, I get,
I'm very excited by all of the colors
that I see in the halftones between the
lights and the shadows.
So these white p and A's have an infinite,
infinite variety of color
in those half tones.
I also love the variety of shapes
in the pns and colors and sizes.
And here I also am painting hydrangeas.
Those are all so fun to paint
and most of all for me,
pianists have a real life force about
the mine titled this painting. She,
because the challenge for
me is to get the life, the,
the essence of these p and ls.
And um,
so I that was a,
this is she for that reason.
Okay.
So I want to explain to you,
show you how I actually set up a design,
make an arrangement and um, and then, uh,
decide until it's until I'm satisfied
with it. Because as Benson said,
design makes the picture good.
Painting can never save a picture
of the composition as bad.
Okay.
So in this set up,
I was interested in getting what's
called a cure Schiro effect. I,
I was interested in a very dark
background with a bright flowers,
um, uh, shining out, uh,
with a lot of light on them.
The problem with this though is I sat
with it for a few days was that there
really wasn't a good, powerful center of
interest. Everything was pretty similar.
So there are a lot of little flux
here and, and not particularly, um,
catching eye catching.
So I added in some white panties for
interest and started playing around with
these. But the problem here was that they
were too spotty. So I've got one here,
one here,
and I'm not really interested in
sort of into it individual panties.
I'm interested in massing them together
and seeing what they do as a big
abstract shape.
Yeah.
So I started doing that and trying to
get something interesting and notice also
that I'm starting to play around
with the background flowers.
Make those
okay.
Harmonized with the, um,
with the center of interest.
Because you want your
background to accentuate it,
but you don't want it to take
away from the center of interest.
It's Paul used to say,
you don't want something in the backstage
to be jumping out saying, look at me,
look at me.
So you're interested in a center of
interest that's complemented by the
background.
So I'm continuing for a few days.
This was interesting,
but it was a little too symmetrical here.
Okay,
now I'm getting a little bit closer.
Yeah.
And finally, this is the finished
painting that I, that I, um,
was happy with them. The design. There's
some interesting negative shapes.
There's an interesting massive light here,
a movement or just you're
among the flowers that's um,
that's uh,
accentuated by the background and
then also notes of red and it's,
it's predominantly a
yellow and blue painting.
And I consider the green to
be part of the yellow family.
And then I've added some for interests,
some coral notes here.
So now I'll show you start to
finish how actually do a painting.
And this is another set up
in my studio. Um, and, uh,
the canvas,
as you can see,
a side by side and I'm standing fairly
far back in order to see the whole thing
at once.
So these would be my first marks really.
This is like maybe the first 20 minutes
of working with a very large brush and a
very blurred I,
because I'm looking to see the big
abstractions of light as it falls across
this,
um,
set up and also the biggest
color values that I can find.
So this is sort of the approximate
color and value of the lightest area,
which would be the P and A's.
And then this is the background,
the dark notes around it.
Actually, this is the background.
This is the dark shadow.
So what I'm trying to get them
approximately the right place.
This is now I'm getting more
of the lay in, it's called.
So this would be the first,
probably 30 minutes or one
hour of doing this painting.
Again, big abstractions of light and
shadows. I'm not painting objects, um,
painting, um, masses of lights.
So for that reason you can see that
there's a law one edge on one side of the
flower that I'm, that I'm starting to, um,
delineate.
There we go.
And what I'm interested in here is how
that edge dissolves into the dark shadow
along the vase and where that is an
approximate relation to the edge of the
canvas. So I'm continuing to
search for my light masses.
I'm letting tones dissolve the
background that are called half tones.
I'm looking for the leading edge.
These would be the hour baskets called.
There are no lines in nature,
so I don't paint around anything.
I'm just painting edges and the
variety of edges that my eyes sees.
And also you might notice that I've
only painted the left side of this vase
because for compositional reasons that
was very important to me. For one thing,
the shadow dissolves into this shadow,
but also the arm here has a
relationship to the arc of this,
um,
flower up here and through this shadow.
This was very important
to me in the design.
And I want to make sure that I've
got this fairly well delineated,
delineated at an early stage of
the painting. And then there's a,
there's sort of a secondary
line or movement here.
So, um, and this would be
the, what's called the s, uh,
the big look for the start.
At this point,
I've got everything going pretty well.
Um,
I've got the visual orders, so
the, the areas that are, um,
that jump out at your eye when you
blur your eyes also come forth and,
or come forward on the canvas and areas
that dissolve recede on the canvas.
So it's, it's what my eye
sees when I blur it. Um, very,
uh, uh, with a very blurred,
I, I'm also looking for,
for shifts, shifts of value, and also
shifts of color. So I'm looking for rare.
My read, my, um, I'm sorry,
my yellows dissolve into bluenotes and um,
just color shifts all over here.
Also,
it has the appearance of,
of images coming out of a fog,
which is, um, also that
lost and found look.
So the rest will be refinements.
So I'll go area by area
now and start painting.
Uh, the, the, um, top
left here was one area.
So again,
I'm not painting objects,
I'm painting areas of
light and shadow and how,
where are they dissolve into one another.
Uh,
this is also when I'm
working area by area.
I'm working in the way that we call
painting from the back straggler.
So if you can imagine a shepherd who's
hurting a flock of sheep from one pasture
to the next, he moves that big
flock of sheep, sheep belong,
but he might have a small group that
sort of lagging behind and those are his
back stragglers.
So he goes and he pulls those flock of
sheep forward and then another flock of
sheep will lag behind. So we're
painting from the back straggler here.
And in this case, as you, you're,
you're trying to get the whole
ensemble moving pretty much at once,
but obviously you have
to paint area by area.
You can't paint the whole
painting all at one time.
So the back straggler for me would be
this bottom right hand area and that's
what I would have painted
the, uh, probably the next,
after I painted this area,
I would have gone and
painted in this area.
So I'm always also pushing
the light effect here.
Okay.
Looking for big colors shifts.
And um,
at this point everything is,
is pretty well defined and
I'm fairly happy with it,
but it doesn't have the harmony or the
unity of the setup of the concept that
I'm looking for. And it's important to
understand. We're not copping simply,
blindly copying nature.
We're looking for something bigger,
that breadth that I was
talking about earlier.
So I'm working day to day, pulling
back, looking for the biggest,
biggest relationships I can see with a
big blurred I with these hydrangeas and
how they relate to the whole ensemble.
Okay.
I often use a mirror,
which I look at upside down because it
reverses everything backwards and upside
down and it helps me see
what the very fresh eye,
okay.
So this was my finished painting and I
couldn't find any more back stragglers
here.
It has the harmony that I was
looking for and the big look,
it also has the vibrancy and the
lights and the shadows and um,
unity, strong light effect,
magical color relationships,
all very important in this painting.
Okay.
So I wanted to,
um,
okay,
just tell you a little bit about,
you can see a lot of the early Boston
school paintings at the Museum of Fine
Arts and Contemporary
Boston school painters. Uh,
a number of us are members of
the guild of Boston artists,
which was founded by Tarbell and Benson
and decamp and the early Boston school
painters. It's a nonprofit
gallery on Newbury street. And uh,
continues today. We just celebrated
our hundredth anniversary. So I'm,
this is actually a photo of the gallery
in 1914 for the inaugural exhibition.
And the gallery is still there.
This mantle is still there and now
they're paintings of contemporary Boston
school and also other wonderful painters
painting in a different traditions,
tonal list, uh, Hudson River
school, some fabulous painters.
So encourage you to take a look at the
gallery and see these paintings for
yourself. Some of the, uh, just a few
of those painters are Mary Menifee,
his wonderful portrait painter,
and also does beautiful still lives.
Okay.
David Curtis, who's also a
student of Ives gamble, uh,
like my teacher and he paints
wonderful. Still lifes, I'm sorry,
landscapes on the north shore.
Okay.
Anita Johnson who paints all kinds of
figurative work as well as I'm still
alive.
Okay.
And Pamela Penn, Dell who was, um,
a student of Robert Hunter's and
um, does a number of different, uh,
paintings as well as sculpture and
beautiful drawings as you can see here.
Okay.
So, um, thank you very much. Also,
I appreciate being able to use the images
from the art renewal center and I'll
take any questions that you have.
Okay.
That was great. Thank
you. Um, I'm curious, oh,
give him the longevity
of the Boston school.
Is there any obligation on the part of
you as a student or other students to go
out and become teachers on your own?
Yes, I absolutely, I'm,
I'm deeply appreciative of Pauling son
because he is passing this on and there
are other teachers,
other people teaching this.
I'm actually throughout the country.
Um,
but I think we as students do
have an obligation to pass it on.
And I do some teaching myself. Merry men
of fee also teaches David Curtis stages.
So there are a number of us who were,
I'm endeavoring to pass
this very valuable painting,
traditional one to the next generation.
So if there are no more questions,
I thank you all for coming today.
Yeah.